ca was du verstanden
wegen fußball guckt was soll's
verhältnismäßig jungen etwas gedacht und
herzlich willkommen bei einem neuen
video das tust du jetzt ja ich hab's
vergessen zu machen hast du mal bei
einem neuen video ja ich hoffe natürlich
jedes gut ich habe letztens falls es den
ersten paar noch nicht gesehen hat
jacqueline esen ab und zwar geht es
heute um die weiteren 15 meter produkte
ich habe dass du schon ersten part
gemacht also generell geht es um alle
milka sorten aus dem supermarkt es gibt
insgesamt 30 stück die ersten 15 habe
ich schon getestet weitere 15 fehlen
noch nie 14 dann waren es nur 29 oder so
ich glaube 27 auf jeden fall noch mal
kurz für euch als erinnerung wir hatten
hier joghurt auf platz eins hat für zehn
von zehn punkte bekommen fand ich echt
geil haben wir auch sehr viele in den
kommentaren zugestimmt dass sie es auch
geld finden und auf dem letzten platz
lag 100 5 von 10 punkten
wusstest du dass es mit pocket ich auch
nicht schmeckt auch nicht also war meine
meinung darf ich ein kommentar gelesen
der von über 230 mill com mit tobis
beste alles klar
tut mir leid fand ich jetzt nicht so nah
ist genau das hier sind die letzten 14
sorten die ich alle noch nicht probiert
habe vielleicht kannst du einmal
überdenken
guck mal das muss man sich mal
vorstellen guck mal das muss man sich
mal vorstellen jede schokolade oder die
meisten schokoladen haben 15 einzelne
teile drin weste
das heißt wenn ich jetzt 14 teile esse
oder 14 stücke wenn ich insgesamt bei
einer ganzen tafel schokolade die ich
jetzt besser ist schon viel und letzte
mal links wir danach echt nicht so gut
gut aber zu machen ich bin halt youtuber
dann muss man auch mal durch und ich
studiere noch um gefällt gerade auf
wieso auch immer hier alten sich ist
genau die war noch zu ihr habe ich
letztes mal mit acht punkten hier
positioniert weil ist halt so da fragt
was war so der auslandspresse
ok weiter geht's eure aufgabe ist
natürlich eurem wunschprodukte in die
kommentare zu schreiben mit denen ich
das mal machen soll
aus dem supermarkt lasst es mich wissen
abonniert den kanal kind tag 19 uhr
neues video
wir machen mit apple weiter
machen nicht mit erdbeer weiter wir
machen mit ich sehe ich da so viele
sorten die kenne ich sogar zum teil
kommen was auch dann machen wir vorne
weiter mit collage also das sind nüsse
schokostückchen und himbeere halt drin
war okay würde ich mal sagen erstes
stück am und was wenn du so große stücke
partie tennis dann geht's dir nachher
nicht schlecht
erstmal reinkommen guck mal das ist fast
ein bisschen sieht auch im kopf fand ich
echt lecker also war gut waren richtig
kann sich richtig gemacht so dieses
bisschen himberg bisschen schokolade
ganz bisschen lust weißt du was es ist
zwar jetzt also da kriegt direkt 19
punkte
prima hast du das hier ist ein ranking
das hier ist müsste das ranking sein
falls da nicht irgendwas durcheinander
gekommen ist aber ich kann natürlich
noch mal alles kontrollieren wir machen
ein neues ranking ich habe hass
durcheinander gebracht was durcheinander
gebracht
aber hier ist ja absurd oder mal ein
neues männchen auf der anderen seite mit
himbeeren verzieren
gut neun von zehn startplätzen meine
haare doch alles klar
dank jetzt das nicht als nächstes
checken wir amerika was das denn
gesalzenes karamell mit extra cacau
das ist hier neu new genau nach
durchschnitt so meine ich dass ich den
new karamell feiert keine frage das
lecker man muss natürlich hier zu sagen
das ist da kostet also dunkle schokolade
tat bitter aufgenommen ist oder
vielleicht punkte und zwar bitter obwohl
da bin ich jetzt auch über fragt
vielleicht auch nicht naja ich weiß
nicht korrigiert mich in den kommentaren
ich muss sagen das schmeckt sehr
weihnachtlich und sie bringt so ein
bisschen was bei nacht und weißt du ich
weiß nicht woran es liegt
passt allerdings nicht weil wir haben
wir september ich muss wirklich sagen
normalerweise feiere ich bin karamell
und schokolade ist aber dass das passt
nicht zusammen dieses dunkle und
parallel dazu das klingt jetzt auch
total hier am zahn kriegt 15 tut mir
leid 0,6 auf technik machen wir weiter
hier mit luft kann ich nur kurze story
zu erzählen und zwar früher beim freibad
wir sind damals zur tankstelle darüber
gelacht weil da gab es günstigere sachen
als im freibad kiosk und da haben wir
uns immer von einer anderen marke diese
luft viel schokolade geholt einfach weil
man eine größere packung für weniger
geld bekommen hat weil der luft drin ist
weiß aber die schokolade ist er größer
und deswegen haben wir die gekauft und
ja immer geil geschmeckt schwenker hat
die alpenmilch ein bisschen luft drinnen
ne das wäre unfair wenn ich da mehr oder
weniger und liebe deswegen trägt das
genauso wie die alpenmilch aus der
ersten folge ab 13
kommt für alex wir haben ja nur noch
zehnter dann kommen wir jetzt mal zu
weißer schokolade
ich weiß nicht ob ich hier schon mal von
make-up probiert habe allerdings bin ich
ein fan von weißer schokolade also ich
mag das mal richtig gerne auch ich hatte
mal so eine phase da habe ich das sogar
lieber gegessen als dunkle oder normale
schokolade vor allem so ein bisschen wie
sagt man genoss geraspelt auf eis das
ist schon länger du altes leckermaul
kann das gar nicht mehr so viel aber
doch ganz gut
schon nach neun von zehn
ich war schon gerade hingeht oder jetzt
sehen wollen sind nicht aus aber es ist
schon lecker wenn da jetzt auch noch
junge tritt wird dann wärst du 11 10
weil hier ist der joghurt auf zehn
punkte gesamt macher weiter mit ach mir
fällt grad auf erdnüsse für das hatten
wir schon im letzten paar deswegen kann
die zur seite hey bin ich blöd diese art
ist schon auf juli das tun fehler
gemacht also die muss auch aus hatte
juri falsch gesehen weißt du weißt schon
offen
diese rosette nie die heiß genug nur
selbst kommt aus frankreich
no ass et ich hatte lange französisch
deswegen kann ich mich dass du brauchst
so dann haben wir dennoch kommen
wir machen jetzt einfach mal erdbeeren
da bin ich mir auch ziemlich sicher dass
mich das immerhin wird das recht auf
allein und hielt auch beim brüten leicht
langsam auf der zunge zergehen lassen
erst anfang der etwa geschmack wird vom
ein gedicht das ist so ein richtiger
anspruch im ressort ein gedicht erinnert
mich sehr an diese schokolade
ummantelten erdbeeren die man auf jeder
klima zu bekommen und das ist halt
einfach extrem lecker deswegen muss ich
da einfach sagen
zehn von zehn sieht halt mit der joghurt
schokolade von maximal gleich mit also
wir haben zwei erste plätze dexheimer
noch dann habe ich es hinter mir
wir machen weiter mit dass das fest über
ikea immer klappt es jetzt echte cloud
jedes mal wenn wir die kollegen so eine
packung drauf gemacht einige treffen das
war genau kann man ist jetzt hier sein
aber ich habe mal gesagt hey ich hab
jetzt für so viel geld eingekauft
da kann man noch mal so ein jailhouse
stützen ich weiß das gibt stand macht
das nicht nach also haben wir jetzt ganz
normale schokolade mit karamell
stückchen hast du auch hier gehört auch
auf jeden fall meiner lieblings
schokoladen würde ich ja ich habe mich
geoutet als karamell fein ca
hast du verstanden wegen fußball club
weist das war als fan ist noch ungewiss
also keine zehn pferde ich mal nicht
mehr geschmeckt hat nach schokolade
karamell ist auf jeden fall gleich aber
keine 10 10 19
durch dieses erdbeer dingen hier mehr um
der haut kommt hier zwischen zac kommen
wir als nächstes zu orio das muss man
nicht mehr vorstellen kann es sein dass
man die gleichen unternehmen die melker
gehört wahrscheinlich weil die haben so
viele kollaborations nicht auf vier
stück insgesamt ich hatte im letzten
fahrt schon einige aber die berichte
schon halt auseinander
ich wollte schon sagen da kann jetzt
nichts für mich bin jetzt nicht der
größte fan also ich also wie gehabt habe
schon das wort fan gesagt ich bin aber
alex wie fällen deswegen sollten wir an
jetzt steuerlichen kanal abonnieren ich
bin nicht der größte fan weshalb ich
auch jetzt hier gesagt hätte die wird
mir nicht so gut schmecken aber sie
hatten wir gut geschmeckt komischerweise
warum auch immer
deswegen gibt es hier von mir andere
brachte acht von zehn punkte und mir
fällt nichts mehr ein was ich dazu sagen
kann das gut schmeckt lecker empfehle
ich euch ja ich hab's geschafft trotzdem
jetzt mit viel wärme einmal triple co kg
kuppelshow cacau genau weiß ist er
schokolade haben dann david mandel
taubes bisschen und wunsch cacau linsen
hh weißt du was den namen smarties sucht
hier nämlich nicht verwendete
urheberrechtlich geschützt markenrecht
schlimmeren weiter mit schüssel schock
sie könnten das sind sie da ziemlich
nach so ist das mit füllung jaja für
opel sieht aus wie dieses comex handel
also darf man die soße besten alter wenn
ich davon die ganze bank würde würde ich
nicht schaffen die ist so mächtig wird
extrem krank nach schokolade ist für
meinen geschmack ein bisschen zu viel
deswegen gibt es auch nur sechs von zehn
tut mir leid hat man nicht gerade mir
gerade hat man mehr und sie landet dann
genau hier haben wir darf mit wandelt
[Applaus]
damit da müsste jetzt auf das was ich
sage
diese man schmeckt so als hätte sie
vorher sony irgendwie wäre schokolade
drin gewesen und sie hätte die
schokolade weggerutscht und dann wieder
schokolade darum gemacht sodass
geschmeckt kennst du nicht diesen
lustigen clip wo das egal
auf jeden fall ist das wirklich nicht
schlecht ist davon ein ist aber eine
neue variante acht kommen ist eigentlich
scheißegal zwei von zehn da will ich
jetzt auch gar nicht gegen die sympathie
punkte geben
zwei fonds entschuldigung dann haben wir
jetzt noch zu guter letzt die bunte
cacau linsen
in callas und danach noch trauben uster
hat auch extreme schokolade ist ja
unsere schokolade drin
deswegen muss ich hier sage nacht von 10
man muss mehr vorstellen ich habe jetzt
in zwei tagen 30 meter schokoladen
bewertet willkommen auf youtube mal
gucken was als nächstes dran ist und zu
guter letzt mit trauben muss ich habe
gerade eine pause
er hat aber geschmeckt wie eine rosine
er getrocknet sind rosig
ich fand die rosine auf jeden fall geld
also kann man machen
weißt du was erleben was zum abschluss
ganz entspannt neun von zehn und haben
dann wirklich viele gute sachen erst
testen können guck mal hier alles neu
trauen muss ja lecker weiße schokolade
ist meiner meinung nach und kakao linsen
auch lecker und dann hatten wir die
einzige zehn von zehn meter erdbeer hat
mich brutal überzeugt werde ich jetzt
öfter genießen abends wenn ich mir
irgendwas an guckt im fernsehen
ich meine natürlich auch netflix oder so
kläglich gescheitert ist die taktik
wandeln kann ich nicht empfehlen
das war zu dem video schreibt für eure
würde ich in die kommentare gibt doch
nach oben für weitere parks abonniert
den kanal jeden tag 90 mal das video
instagram alex wir und alter so viel
schokolade habe ich noch nie in zwei
tagen gegessen